main dans la main ils déambulent dans
les rues de chartres comme n'importe
quel couple d'amoureux gata kamsky grand
maître international d'échecs et son
épouse vers 1 et paul signac en ski
grand maître également ils ont choisi de
poser leurs valises à charge un choix de
raison et de coeur
historique et le monde moderne
[Musique]
les gens
les gens que je rencontre qui
ma femme a été admise à l'université en
france et l'un de nos amis nous a tout
de suite recommandé de venir à chartres
car ici la mairie soutien de beaucoup
les échecs le président du club nous a
d'ailleurs tout ouïe très bien accueilli
à terme ces temps gata kamsky fait
partie du gotha mondial ce russe
naturalisé américain a été double
vainqueur de la coupe du monde d'échecs
et cinq fois champion d'échecs des états
unis il arrive à chartres précédé de
cette réputation
son ambition faire des joueurs français
les futurs champions du monde d'échecs
[Musique]
mon projet aujourd'hui est d'aider et
entraîner de nouveaux joueurs j'ai envie
de partager mes connaissances et de voir
progresser les jeunes talents qui sont
très prometteurs ici
[Musique]
la cams qui veut poursuivre ses études
de langues entraîné le public féminin et
surtout être au plus près de son
[Musique]
diplôme travail en équipe la ville de
chartres a une réelle passion pour les
tournois d'échecs elle est devenue une
terre d'élection du champion
petit écran on a la chance d'avoir une
municipalité qui nous suivent d'abord et
qui croient aux échecs donc ça c'est
très très important et on a vu qu'avec
les tournois l'organisation du top 12
les championnats de france où il ya eu
plus de 1000 personnes c'était viable
par rapport à la vie on a besoin
beaucoup de formateurs d'avoir une
méthode ça va ça va fonctionner comme ça
désormais chartrain de couple de
champions vise une nouvelle partie leur
naturalisation française